une visite hautement symbolique quelques
jours après l'arrestation de l'auteur
présumé des attaques contre le centre
LGBTI de Touraine la ministre à
l'égalité femme homme veut rassurer et
adressé un message de fermeté aux
auteurs LGBTI car si le calme est revenu
l'inquiétude persiste chez les militants
soulager néanmoins vigilant notre notre
association reste quand même vulnérable
à tous ces actes de vandalisme nous
l'avons vu au corps aujourd'hui et même
hier sur les passages arc-en-ciel de la
ville de Tours qui ont été une nouvelle
fois dégradées et c'est d'ailleurs c'est
hostilité de plus en plus affiché qui a
décidé Isabelle Longvic Rome à faire le
déplacement alors que ce profil la
Marche des fiertés samedi prochain la
ministre en a profité pour dresser les
grandes lignes d'un nouveau plan de
lutte contre la haine dans le tille
LGBTI qui sera dévoilé dans quelques
jours on nous engageons à notamment à
renforcé pour les formations des
policiers et des gendarmes mais aussi de
très professionnel de sécuriser encore
davantage les lieux qui sont qui peuvent
être
des lieux de risque d'agression et puis
de travailler aussi en termes de
prévention de sensibilisation et de
répression des mesures qui satisfont les
militants qui espèrent maintenant des
moyens supplémentaires pour accomplir
leur mission de sensibilisation dans les
écoles 1500 jeunes tours en jouant
rencontrés l'an dernier nous sommes
subventionnés cependant puisque notre
action grandit des subventions on
l'espère vont grandir avec pour qu'on
puisse accomplir le mieux possible cette
action qui est très importante qui est
la prévention du harcèlement des
discriminations dans les collèges et des
lycées présents également le préfet
d'Indre-et-Loire a annoncé le
renforcement de la sécurité pour la
Marche des fiertés à Tours entre 2 et
3000 personnes défileront samedi